good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy friday
human beings have been wondering about
unexplained lights in the night sky
since the first neanderthal cooked an
ocelot over a campfire and looked up
but in our age in the modern age
fascination with ufos really began
in the summer of 1947. that's when a man
called mack
brazell found something very weird on
his ranch in corona new mexico that's
about 85 miles northwest of roswell
suspecting it might be debris from outer
space brazil dutifully brought the
pieces to a nearby military base
the next day the base issued a press
release confirming that the material was
in fact
from a flying disk a flying saucer
news agencies around the world announced
the shocking fine flying saucers
then within hours the u.s military
changed its assessment
of what these pieces were brigadier
general roger ramey commander of the 8th
air force
announced that in fact the debris from
outside roswell was nothing more than a
weather balloon
not a big deal nothing extraordinary
certainly nothing extraterrestrial
was general raimi telling the truth
about that well looks like he may have
been
it may in fact have been a weather
balloon but that was not the end of the
story
over the past 75 years the u.s military
has gathered evidence on a remarkable
number of puzzling aerial phenomena
most of which were definitely not
weather balloons
unexplained flying objects have buzzed
u.s military bases
missile sites ships aircraft submarines
underwater
often at speeds and in directions that
seem to defy
any known human technology the pentagon
has said next to nothing about any of
this in public instead it has
consistently
covered up these sightings virtually
everything we know about ufos has come
from whistleblowers
by the time this show launched nearly
five years ago it was clear there was
definitely something
very odd going on in the skies above us
ufos were not some
crackpot theory cooked up on late night
radio they were
absolutely real the question was
what are they exactly over the years
several powerful
political figures in washington
including senator harry reid
have pushed the u.s military to reveal
all it knows about ufos
but in every case they have failed to
dislodge that information
then last year senator marco rubio of
florida inserted a demand for
transparency into a federal
appropriations bill
by the end of june 2021 the government
was required to turn over its full
assessment of ufos
just a few hours ago that report finally
came out
late on a friday we've only seen the
public version so far but here's what we
can tell you
government investigators seem sincerely
baffled by what these things are
today's report analyzed 144
separate sightings of ufos by the us
military but in only a single case could
the government explain
what it was in that case it was a large
deflating balloon
the rest the other 143 remain a complete
and total mystery
so the most sophisticated military in
the world has no idea what these things
are or even how they move from place to
place
some of these aircraft the report says
quote appeared to remain
stationary in winds aloft move against
the wind maneuver abruptly or move at
considerable speed
all without discernible means of
propulsion
so we do know that no government in the
world possesses anything like this
no technology like this exists that we
know of the pentagon seems fairly
certain these are not russian and
they're not
chinese so what are they the report
doesn't say it notes only the obvious
ufos quote clearly pose a safety of
flight issue and may pose a challenge to
u.s national security end quote
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else